en el corazón del Himalaya se encuentra
un país pequeño
sin salida al mar entre India y China
bután es una región montañosa con cerca
de tres cuartos de un millón de
habitantes
también es uno de los pocos países del
Mundo con emisiones de carbono negativas
y Afirma absorber más CO2 del que emite
miremos aquí a la izquierda
un éxito que puede relacionarse con los
bosques del país vastos pulmones verdes
que absorben las emisiones de carbono
representan alrededor del 70% de su
territorio y están protegidos por la
Constitución miren a su alrededor
nuestro país sabe proteger sus bosques
todo ello gracias a nuestro duro trabajo
Estos árboles son la fuente de la vida
absorben contaminantes como el carbono y
liberan oxígeno
para conseguir una huella de carbono
negativa bután absorbe sus emisiones
pero también intenta limitarlas
la producción de Electricidad del país
no procede de combustibles fósiles sino
que se abastece al 100% de energía
hidráulica
este es nuestro envase
de una de las cinco represas del país
cuando llega el agua la bloqueamos aquí
y luego la desviamos al túnel
gracias a la energía hidráulica bután es
líder en energías renovables
[Música]
Se podría decir que El combustible que
utilizamos es agua Así que es muy limpio
cualquier país puede utilizar la energía
hidroeléctrica siempre y cuando tenga
ríos y el paisaje adecuado qué es lo que
tenemos
enorgullece de ser un país en emisiones
de carbono pero hasta cuándo
con una población creciente las
emisiones de carbono van a aumentar
aquí en Tim Bull la capital del país el
número de coches ha aumentado
drásticamente en los últimos años
las autoridades han tomado medidas
drásticas introduciendo coches
eléctricos para convencer a los
conductores
el plan del gobierno consiste en
subvencionar a los taxistas
este conductor acaba de hacer el cambio
Soy argentino el gobierno nos da 4500
euros el resto es en préstamos esto es
bueno para nuestro futuro
para reducir el dióxido de carbono y los
niveles de contaminación
lejos de la ciudad los pueblos de bután
también quieren hacer del medio ambiente
una prioridad
en este consejo de la aldea estas
cuestiones dominan el orden de la agenda
hace poco multamos a alguien que fue
sorprendido tirando basura de plástico
bután quiere mantener el desarrollo
sostenible como piedra angular de su
cultura
somos muy Afortunados de vivir en un
país que ha puesto en marcha medidas a
largo plazo para que sigamos siendo
respetuosos con el medio ambiente no se
nos permite contaminar nuestros suelos y
se perseveran nuestros bosques Esto es
lo que diferencia a bután de otros
países para reducir sus emisiones el
país también regula el turismo
imponiendo una tasa de 200 euros por día
a todos Los visitantes extranjeros